you don't wanna step on all the candy
that's a lot there hi so my talk is
called the other side of empathy and
I'll get into what that exactly means
pretty soon but a kind of apt
description is kind of an intro into
encouraging exemplifying empathy so
again hello so who am i why am i up here
how did I get here so i am nick her hair
if you're from Germany I am first and
foremost an empathetic community member
I am a maintainer of the one of the
hoodie projects one of the many
different modules that they have and
they put out I am recently a tehsil to
hustle project team member and I am also
an organizer of a meetup in New York
called Manhattan jas so one of the many
barojah so yeah we had a couple of
people here tonight who have spoken
there too and then you can find me
online at a hipster brown so look for
charlie brown with a mustache and that's
me and if you may have noticed now I
have a pretty wicked mustache but
important thing to note as it's not to
be touched it may sound like a weird
request but it's happened before so just
going to put it out there so yeah why am
I here talking about empathy why do I
care so much about it I could say it's
because I study psychology and
leadership in college and not really CS
but really learn more about how people
work together it could be because I as a
front-end developer I'm causative
collaborating with different types of
people different backgrounds Putte
designers or developers but for the most
part it's just because I love community
and the JavaScript community and the web
development community and node BOTS and
all these type of things it's the
community that led me into exploring
those options it's the people there that
keep me there and make me want to work
more and maybe going to work on open
source and contribute back
and I just really love it and now who
else should care it's a pretty easy
question everybody I know crazy right
it's really wild but it's something that
we should all care about because it
impacts all of us you all are here today
because you care about something you
care about learning you care about
talking and meeting with other people in
the community or you care about candy or
shirts that you get at the at the front
so it's called the other side of empathy
but what is empathy we may have heard it
as like seeing the world through the
eyes of someone else taking the walk in
someone else's shoes and it's very
general it doesn't give a lot of apt
description but I like to think of it as
the ability to understand and share the
feelings of another that's not
necessarily all feelings and emotion but
feeling it able to understand and
connect with them is really true empathy
as I see it so where did the other side
of empathy come from so as anyone who
uses Twitter there tends to be some
negative thoughts that come out
something comes something new comes out
like maybe the Instagram icon that got
released yesterday and there are many
snap judgments that people come up with
their people who instantly have
something and they take to Twitter and
it's like 140 characters firing off 10
10 11 and then this mob mentality forms
around it and it's just a layer of
negativity that's hard to get through
and it must say just really bums me out
and it's hard to see some of the
positive sides of the internet when
stuff like that happens and I wanted to
be able to see and connect with those
people and be like but if you knew the
person who worked on that would you say
to their face which you able to connect
with them that way and if you knew could
empathize with them would you say the
same thing and we've heard from Rachel
about how she was so fearful of
contributing and becoming part of the
open source community because of those
negative things that happen it's not
just Twitter
and in a lot of open communities so how
can resolve that how can we add empathy
and encourage it from our perspective
and get and receive it as well so the
other side is encouraging it as well as
be able to receive it back so it breaks
down into kind of four tenants I like to
say one of them is context constructive
feedback as rachel has mentioned before
communication is very important and last
of all caring and these are kind of what
I'll be going through in-depth and
describing kind of how these apply to my
everyday job and as well as how I
impacted by the open source community
and things I've learned from it as well
so I gave you all that but that
background knowledge that's basically a
context so another description that
internal external factors that influence
the decisions we make any actions we
take internally could be subconscious it
could be something or could be external
factors by the way people we've learned
from others so it relates into this
other side theory in that no one is
unoffending dated we have something that
we we have some kind of bias that we
have we may not recognize it right away
but it's there we've heard of onion
pending native frameworks but the fact
that it's not a framework but a library
or a bunch of modules is an opinion
about how they want to structure their
project we all have biases like I said
it may recognize it or not an important
part of contexts listening if someone's
trying to give you some from information
and you're not listening or we're not
listening back then it just kind of
negates the whole part of empathizing
with them and of course asking why and
asking why in a good way in an
intentional way and wanting to learn
from it and just continue asking why
until we find out and can connect with
them and not why in a condescending way
like rachel has heard from before and
kind of feigning ignorance and we can do
this a bit more and set the example
around giving context and receiving it's
a great way that I've done it at work
and in have been courage to do it
or in open source projects is code
comments coke comments are really easy
way for people to read through a snippet
of code and understand what the author
was thinking about during that time it's
the ability for someone to jump into the
authors Bryan say what the heck were
they thinking or that teklet was I
thinking while writing this bit of code
and as especially in hardware I've
become more aware of how important this
is so this is something actually
straight out of the tehsil CLI it's
dealing with node chip which is binary
modules doesn't really matter but seeing
that but python is inside this no script
might help clear up why the heck this is
here it without all this kind of story
and train of thought that we could
follow along with we wouldn't really be
able to follow that if we had to
continue with it later or if someone
else is trying to jump to the project
contribute and salt just a bunch of
nonsense they're like why is this here
I'll just remove it and then we can just
remember what's going on again and so
remembering contexts for me comes in
kind of four steps I generally take a
deep breath and then I try to push aside
some snap judgments that come up I'm
very clear on recognizing what comes up
acknowledging those biases and trying to
see where they come from but making sure
that's not the first thing that comes
out of my mouth sincerely asking why why
did they choose to do this thing where
did this context come from and then
listening really really listening and
trying to pull in and parse what they're
saying and then asking why if you don't
understand again don't make assumptions
and sincerely try to connect with them
and once we get that context and once we
give our context as well we might start
asking for constructive feedback and
understanding and getting to get
responded with embeth empathy so
constructive feedback very simply put is
the return of information that helps to
do
or improve anything it can be a blog
post code design and it's that
constructive part of it that is key
there's negative feedback startup
criticism isn't great either and we just
want or even positive feedback and I'll
go into that as well so we may have
heard when we were younger at least when
I went to school it was a lot of if you
don't have anything nice to say then
don't say it at all kind of the golden
rule or do unto you what you would have
done or something like that and
somewhere between great school or
primary school were taught that we tend
to kind of lose it we don't remember
where it came from or even as we come
adults why we should keep remembering
this and for this talk I specifically
want to talk about this constructive
part of it so when giving feedback just
saying that looks great that's that's
that rocks is and we're at when we're
genuinely asking for constructive
feedback that doesn't really help yes
and so we're going to want to ask for
another thing to constructive to say
don't say anything at all we may have
seen like github comments the +1 it's
great to get that feedback but it's just
going to annoy cause noise for that fee
that issue we want to get genuine
constructive feedback and help people
using it or make it help it improve
later on and then some people kind of
have brought up before what about
negative feedback and as I've talked to
some people on Twitter before again back
with Twitter a negative feedback can
might make change but good feedback
takes more than 140 characters as Rachel
maver reference before getting feedback
and trying to get help on Twitter it's
really hard you lose context people jump
in to random bits of the conversation
not seeing what was happening before and
not just getting enough information to
give a really helpful comments yeah the
whole hundred forty characters problem
maybe we shouldn't use Twitter for that
type of stuff sometimes it could be
better ways and so constructive feedback
is mutual mutually agreed upon like
for like Rachel reference before is like
random people coming in for someone's
first contribution when it's generally
not asked for yet if they release it and
people jump in without being knowledge
that they're being asked for
constructive feedback it becomes off as
defensive for the people receiving it
and it set up with expectations okay i'm
getting code review I which I'll
reference soon and the expectation is
that I want you to focus on this part of
the code not this part I recognize that
it's not great but it's going to be
distracting if we start focusing on it
now it's in an open space and by open
space I don't necessarily mean like a
big room I mean in a way that people can
pull back from that feedback if it's too
much for them if it's anxiety driven if
it becomes just too stressful that they
can pull away whenever they want to it's
not someone coming up to their chair and
in saying have some thoughts about this
and they're just like I can't do this
right now there's none and it's also
shared with context we need context
behind why they think this is good
feedback so yeah code brews are a really
easy example at work and in an open
source and there tend to defined in fix
mistakes that are overlooked proving and
overall quality of software and
developer skills overall quality can be
kind of subjective but the fact that
they wouldn't improve it is the big
thing it's not commenting on spelling
mistakes if that's not what's being
focused on for a constructive feedback
and we can encourage it to especially
with an open source there's some great
little things that github is provided
and other platforms as well contributing
md files whenever some ties to open up
or request or create an issue we have
these guidelines for you to view and not
everyone may click on that but they're
available for people to view so my
favorites are the atom projects has some
great guidelines and with emoji and
great descriptions as well as the hoodie
project I'm a little biased but it's
really really perfect they go into all
sorts of things about how the project is
managed and how they can help out in any
way with writing issues and even code
and then recently issue templates
started popping up for github
repositories as well as get lab has had
them for a while and it's great for
setting up okay I need this
back from you I need this context in
order to really help out and so you can
give me proper feedback on something
that's bugging you or something that you
want to help fix and all of this type of
context and constructive feedback comes
through proper communication basically
the successful sharing of ideas and
feelings between people and ultimately
communication is how we interact with
each other we communicate by talking in
the hallways communicate online there
are so many people who I've communicated
solely online and then just got to meet
at conferences and having that solid
communication beforehand helped me feel
more comfortable meeting them in person
so it relates in what we sing how we say
it and where we say it as well in how we
say things I statements are very very
nice for giving constructive feedback
saying I saw this thing that will help
improve this code I believe it's not
good for getting context saying that i
know this is better just because it's
not great for that use statements are
great for getting context why did you
make this decision why did you choose
this library why did you choose to have
this arbitrary number of timeouts but
it's not great for giving constructive
feedback you should fix this you have
done this wrong that's not great and for
communication we have different so many
different mediums communicate through
now at work we communicate through so
many different options and they all have
their own purpose slack is a great
general super quick chats especially for
remote employees or even people around
the office for just quick feedback with
a group stand-ups are great for giving
more in person one to one context and
then recorded scuss ins that comes with
github issues that can be referenced
later and enforce long form or a sync
email is the perfect option we don't
always need an answer right away email
is great to give people time and
measured
back and discussions mailing list might
be another thing but we'll go into that
the note option and we can create
communication I have one point here I
want to touch on the word sucks is kind
of a trigger word for me because it
provides no context it provides no
constructive feedback and just kind of
it's dead in the water as far as
continuing and creating empathy whenever
here someone says something sucks on
Twitter or in just general comments it
doesn't help me it doesn't help the
person who's getting feedback and unless
you're talking about like DJ Roomba
sucks or some kind of other vacuum sucks
has really no beneficial and sometimes
yes something sucks but we can be more
descriptive to help out other people
that said before there are many other
mediums to chat with people especially
online and giving more wide more
characters than 140 to chat with other
people their slack getter IRC that still
exists I know slacks very popular I RC
still exist as well and of course github
and slack I really like because of the
customization options so in the hoodie
slack and some other slacks I've added
this little line in the slack bot to say
when someone said something sucks could
you be more descriptive I don't
understand could you empathize on that
or just different options to try to pull
more information from them so that I can
understand and others can understand
what they're going through and how we
can help fix it and ultimately all these
options they require caring it's
providing the need of something and
showing interest in it genuine interest
in it it's caring is sharing it's
listening and ultimately as I said in
the beginning it's understanding and
connecting with people and we can show
how much we care as contributors and
maintain errs and even people trying to
use and as part of the community around
a project or a library or a person
you care enough to write a blog post to
kind of go through your steps that gives
so much context if we can read a
long-form answer of that you can't have
to file an issue if you have a getup
account and you're able to file an issue
or even sending email as an issue to
someone do you have that time can you
you send the email do you have enough
time to record a screencast that really
helps give a lot of contacts with kind
of arbitrary details that someone might
not add through text I mean pictures
worth a thousand words a screencast will
give you a million and you even have
enough time and availability and care to
submit a pull request I know not
everyone has the technical knowledge or
even the time or even the privilege to
go and contribute to that but if you
have the time and the ability and
someone else is working on something
else overall or just does not have the
bandwidth to do that can you can you
actually start helping at least and then
they can help finish you along the way
and of course don't give in to hate it
leads to the dark side we shouldn't hate
on things in the sense that we care so
much about it that we hate that it's not
getting done it's more about what can we
do to help in any way possible
documentation is super important as
we've been learning more and more
throughout working on open source and
even internally in companies wikis code
comments style guides pattern libraries
even a readme a simple reading can go so
far to helping encourage contributions
or empathy empathizing with the creator
of a project and we can exemplify
carrying in so many different ways I'm
going to embarrass her right now but
it's one of my favorite things that's
kind of recently has been Susan's AVR
girl test pilot it's an example of going
above and beyond caring about
contributors and a community for project
it's an app that she bundled with the
CLI for AVR girl Arduino and it helps
people want to contribute to
automatically run through her hardware
test suite with whatever board they have
on them fast with Arduino and there's so
many out there that this
her not buy everything and helps her
contribute logs about maybe something
went wrong and in their environment that
she can get a lot of context from that
and because they're opting into sharing
what they want they have the option to
be added as a contributor to the project
which is just great it helps that green
graph even though it doesn't mean that
much and shouldn't care too much about
it some people do and they want to see
that on their timeline and see that oh I
helped out this project so Sue's has
made that a great part of encouraging
and caring more about the project and
this is great reasons why to create
something like this manual testing is
boring and she recognizes that you don't
get the little green square and most
people have Hardware know a lot of start
there's lot of assumptions with the
hardware background where oh I know you
know this so just run it and you're fine
or set this up set up a compiler and
you're good to go but not everyone has
that time even for getting started with
hardware and sometimes there's too many
steps involved like I said before who
knows how to cross compile something off
the top of their head or once to even
spend hours googling for that and then
within open source I've been work I've
gotten a lot of mentors mentoring really
matters do you remember starting out and
not knowing any where you're going do
you even have a mentor did you want one
if so why not if you did then what
happened and do you want to learn
mentoring and training teaching will
force you to learn so much about a
subject that you're able to give it back
in a more cohesive and approachable way
and kind of a word of warning about how
much we care and being aware of what we
actually care about I ran into an issue
with this recently for myself at work
and I was starting to care more about a
project in the code involved because I
was working on it so hard and I thought
it would solve a lot of solutions and I
began to ignore something the things
like I cared most about but had just
completely pushed him to the wayside I
was my communication was opaque I didn't
give proper communication or a proper
feedback or pay attention to it as well
from when that was getting feedback from
others and I was putting so much work
and care into just the project I forgot
about the people and the people I had to
work with we it was very embarrassing
for me because I became the hypocrite of
my own message and it code can be easily
tossed aside and built again but
relationship with people either
professionally or personally take more
time to mend and will be proved useful
than any line of code I'll ever writes
if anyone's ever read the ten
commandments of the ego lyst programmer
it applies to so many different things
and that helped me recognize what I was
actually focused on and how wrong I was
and be able to recognize and care enough
to push aside your own ego and try to
connect with others even if it means
pushing aside a project they've worked
so hard on can be difficult but
enormously helpful and contributing back
with empathy and anything we do it could
be just listening for a day just take a
moment and listen to what people are
saying and understand with them apply
the examples that I've gone over we can
start off small too it doesn't have to
be everything at once you can just start
maybe just trying to put a readme in one
of your project repos or just starting
to influence and ask for more code
comments or just asking for feedback
sincerely remaining open to sharing what
others are saying or what you're sharing
as well and be able to communicate with
that with others and some people might
view this and say that still sounds like
a lot of work I'm sorry it's just got to
deal with it it's something that's
really going to matter and it's
something that's going to benefit
everyone because by applying empathy to
what we do we can connect with other
professionally and then begin to
reconnect with others personally some of
my resources so my favorite resource to
get started especially with the type of
empathy I'm speaking about practical
empathy is a great book to start out
with nonviolent communication is really
helpful for recognizing those i use
statements and realizing more about how
we communicate with people creativity
inc if you have noticed i really
Pixar and Disney it's a great way to see
how people work together creatively and
learn more from each other but I also
gather a bunch of resources that aren't
just books at this website I love the
URL and I was fortunate to find it more
empathy online and I've started it back
when I went to jas confi you back some
September but I've fallen to the wayside
unfortunate because of other projects
but I would love your help it is open
source and it's under my repo hipster
brown the other side of empathy and i
created a readme because i realized last
night i did have a readme for it and so
I was like oh I gotta get this up and
get it going and your help would be
enormously helpful like if you saw
something that helped you understand
someone else it could be a blog post a
book a video a podcast even I love
podcast I learned so much from hearing
people talk and listening because
there's no visual distraction and it
really helps and I have some hopefully
very helpful instruction of how to
contribute either on the web or even
through the command line but I know not
everyone is as adept with get on the
command line or even locally so that's
basically it I want you to go out look
for empathy try to understand it and
connect with other people and contribute
to this list for other people to learn
from as well thank you
you